sébastien bouvier bonjour bonjour merci
d'être là nous sommes à l'atelier
numérique à versailles rue saint-simon
voilà pour une raison bien précise
d'abord vous même vous vous occupez une
société qui s'appelle harry pictures
avec votre collègue et néanmoins ami
arthur schouppe a alors expliqué que moi
juste un peu en deux mots qui vous êtes
tous les deux alors donc notre société
de production audiovisuelle harry
pictures a été créé il ya deux ans et
demi suite à la réussite de la
production et de la réalisation d'un
court métrage de science fiction qui
s'appelle arik qu'arthur a réalisé et
pour lequel j'ai recherché des
financements donc dans la foulée de ce
court métrage nous avons créé harry
pictures à la foulée de ce siècle
exactement et nous avons donc deux
activités une activité on va dire
commercial de réalisation de films
publicitaires et en parallèle nous
conservons une activité artistique pour
la production de films de court métrage
et en parallèle nous sommes ici puisque
nous organisons pour la deuxième année
consécutive une soirée de projection de
courts métrages le 21 décembre 2014
d'accord alors je vais juste vous
demander vos commentaires vos activités
artistiques concerne vos propres
réalisations ou vous financez produisent
et d'autres réalisations
alors justement actuellement nous sommes
en appel à projet depuis maintenant
accès manière nous avons lancé un appel
à scénario de court métrage nous
recherchons des scénarios de films à
produire l'idée effectivement c'est de
ne pas produire uniquement d
des films en interne est justement de
nous ouvrir un peu à des artistes
exactement extérieur puisque nous on est
très science fiction nouvelles
technologies on aimerait bien un petit
peu se diversifier dans les genres
exactement des cas donc ok je comprends
donc revenons au 21 décembre donc il
faut savoir que c'est le solstice
d'hiver à savoir le jour le plus court
ce qui a donné j'imagine au cnc l'idée
c'est cnc qui au départ de ça donc le
cnc et l'agent du court métrage
organisent conjointement effectivement
l'événement décor qui consiste en quoi
alors donc chaque année il y à un
catalogue de films de court métrage qui
est mise à disposition pour toute
structure toute personne qui
souhaiterait organiser une soirée de
projection donc on s'inscrit sur le site
le jour le plus court on regarde le
catalogue
qui est visible et donc on soumet une
liste en parallèle et alors on se met
une liste et qui au cnc ah bon deux
films que nous choisissons pas de toute
façon puisqu'il vous les propose
si vous choisissez ils vont passer dire
non tout de même bien sûr mais c'est
uniquement pour que la soirée soit
validée pour que nous puissions y vie
quoi ah oui kiwi ils n'ont pas le droit
de regard sur votre choix parmi leurs
fonctions en aucun cas et ça peut être
n'importe qui après un particulier ou
c'est seulement pour les mairies
généralement c'est plutôt des
établissements publics ou des cinémas
d'accord ok couture prison alors
continuons donc vous choisissez vous
exactement vous envoyer la liste et à
cnc qui vous dit ok géorgie voit les
films et en parallèle on a le droit en
fait de choisir des films qui ne font
pas partie de ce catalogue puisqu'il est
quand même assez restreint ouais ce que
nous fait voyager gagne quoi rien au
jour cette année je crois que nous avons
à peu près dans les 150 films dans le
catalogue
jamais encore un peu plus vous pouvez
par rapport à versailles donc vous vous
occupez de de cet événement là vous
gérez avec arthur tous les deux
exactement voilà vous êtes responsable
de ça et quel est votre angle alors vous
avez un thème comme ça se passe alors
nous on n'a pas forcément un angle par
rapport au genre
on est ouverts où que ce soit la comédie
fantastique film d'action il ya aucun
problème
par contre on aime bien faire un mix
entre le film d'animation et la fiction
c'était le cas l'année dernière nous
avions à peu près deux heures et demie
de films qui ont été projetés et on
avait presque une heure et demie de film
d'animation cette année et cette année
ça va être plutôt inverse d'accord juste
de la fiction exactement hockey dont
vous faites appel à différents
réalisateurs donc ça va durer juste
19h30 je crois le 21 décembre à la télé
numérique c'est gratuit c'est gratuit
les gouvernants 70 places il est alors
l'année dernière on était salle pleine
on a même dû
demander à des gens de partir de partir
ne pouvait pas qu'ils pouvaient pas
justement rentrée donc on conseille de
réserver en fait de réserver exact au
téléphone on téléphone à l'atelier
numérique donne son nom exactement
et voilà les gens qui faisaient
reviennent oui oui bon génial donc ses
21 19h30 jusqu'à ont peut-être minuit on
sait pas c'est aléatoire ça dépend ça
dépend des dalles et on avait gagné
autant de minuit ça finira peut-être
plus tôt cette année puisque quatre
sélections un peu plus courte que ce
domaine et est ce que les réalisateurs
interviennent après le
la diffusion de leur court métrage ou
pas alors l'idée oui ce serait bien
qu'ils interviennent en tout cas ceux
qui vont venir puisque tout ce monde et
ne sont pas présentement la plupart des
courts métrages présentés n'auront pas
leurs réalisateurs présents ce soir là
en tout cas pour ceux qui sont présents
le public était souvent très intéressés
pour savoir comment le film s'est
réalisé bien sûr et questions et
échanger exactement écoutez je vais vous
dire quelque chose de super nous allons
avoir un jeune réalisateur qui sera là
qui va présenter son court métrage qui
s'appelle le bosch et qui sera là pour
en parler après et qui est même là tout
de suite maintenant pour en parler avec
noir fait pas un peu génial ça on est
d'accord merci sébastien je remercie le
21 novembre jean de craie bonjour
bonjour merci nous avoir rejoint
l'atelier numérique pour parler de votre
carrière de vos réalisations et de ce
qui va se passer très prochainement
alors vous vous êtes un jeune
versaillais si je ne m'abuse le feu
voilà vous avez fait des études de
cinéma à l'école 3e 3 2 à la nommer un
drop à trappes
voilà et là aujourd'hui vous êtes avec
nous pour parler d'un court métrage qui
va être diffusé le 21 décembre
l'événement qu'on évoquait tout à
l'heure avec sébastien bouvier la nuit
du pas la nuit le jour jour le plus cool
peu court voilà donc on va reprendre un
peu au début vous à l'art après votre
école de cinéma qu'est ce qui s'est
passé mais cela ne choisit quelle
branche chiante
il s'est passé plusieurs choses moi j'ai
toujours voulu faire de la mise en scène
mais qu'at on entre dans l'école je
voulais en faire mais j'ai vu qu'il me
fallait
si je voulais un peu survivre dans le
milieu tout en faisant des réalisations
il me fallait un métier qui tienne la
route et surtout un métier qui
qui rapportaient de l'argent qu'on
puisse exercer régulière s'est
régulièrement à la donc j'ai pris
l'option montage oui
et du coup en sortant de l'école je suis
devenu assistant monteur tout de suite
réussi à fermer heures intermittence ga
pas facilement mais en tout cas je les
ai fait et je suis parti je pense d peu
de gens qui arrivent à les faire de la
promo en plus si jeune
en plus pas de choses sans expérience
couiza donc c'est que c'est qu'ils
avaient dû y avait du travail trouve
exactement après y'a des milieux plus
faciles que d'autres donc un métier
technique c'était plus c'était plus
facile
assistant monteur monteur de films
courts et puis bah tout mon temps libre
était utilisé pour écrire réaliser
montée des courts métrages de fait
d'accord alors votre votre oeuvre si on
peut dire personnel donc il ya eu un
premier bon il ya eu plein de petits
courts-métrages de on va dire d'essai
voilà et le premier officiel s'appelle
frenchman exactement il est dure 15
minutes
il est sorti quand il a été terminé en
2012 voilà il a fait bouger ces langues
un festival mais c'était un premier
court donc avec pas mal de petits
défauts donc qu'il a eu deux sélections
seulement c'était déjà un bon début mais
ben oui qui voit là et puis je les
montre à des professionnels qui ont
quand même apprécier le travail
l'accepté on était quand même sur le bon
chemin
et puis la cour à gien c'était très
encourageante et puis j'étais content de
l'avoir fini ce que cet avortement vrai
premier projet qui quasi non à la
violence oui du temps une énergie sans
15 minutes c'est long et c'est assez
long en fait et c'est aussi pour ça que
le second ouais comme alain voilà on
maintenant on est au pardon qui
s'appelle le celui qu'on va voir
le 21 décembre exactement
voilà et donc vous allez par les banques
et donc par rapport aux frenchman il
était beaucoup plus ambitieux dans la
mise en scène dans les décors les
costumes cela il fallait commune
ce qu'il faut dire qu'on est très
harmonieux on est en 14 18 en encadrant
et 8 dans les tranchées donc faut que ça
ressemble un tout petit peu à ce qu'on
cherche
et aussi il y avait d'autres défis
c'était que je voulais pas de dialogue
les acteurs allaient avoir des masques à
gaz la plupart du temps nos oreilles
dans la fumée la plupart du temps aussi
donc pour qu'on s'y retrouve un tout
petit peu sans pouvoir identifier
clairement les personnages sans les
entendre tout ça alors que ça bouge ça
se tire dessus où ça se tire pas dessus
on sait pas trop et puis faut qu'une
histoire sais pas il faut qu'une
histoire se passe donc c'était assez
c'était assez ambitieux du coup la
première des choses c'était de faire un
finir pas trop le déjà du coup
effectivement le film géorgie générique
je ne fais que sept minutes reste on a
bien bien réduit pour être le plus
efficace possible ré des cas plus
efficace mais du coup un autre défi
arrivait dans le même temps c'est qu'il
fallait plonger spectateurs en un temps
record quelque sorte dans la guerre
c'est à dire qu'on est en train de
l'installer tranquillement dans une
ambiance fait avec l'ambiance il y croit
dès les premiers plans d'accord parce
que sinon sinon le film avait déjà donné
à 21 ans il tombe bien vous évoquez vous
allez me le dire dans ce court métrage
de bosch
vous évoquez des valeurs comment les
définir l'humaniste way ensemble fasse
aider des valeurs qui parle à tout le
monde sait ça c'est très universel sans
frontières c'est le langage au delà des
paroles donc c'est quelque chose une
histoire d'hommes a exactement 2 c'est
universel et intemporel en tout cas oui
et après plus précisément c'est une
histoire d'amitié c'est l'histoire d'un
minibus et un poids un peu loin c'est un
moment est très précis c'est un moment
fraternel d'un instant tout cas là c'est
devenir frère pendant que nadie miracle
qui n'auraient pas dire que c'est la
petite lumière qui brille au milieu de
l'obscurité
c'est au mans ça comme ça que je le vois
des cas ces deux hommes qui à qui on a
dit tout ce qu'ils portent pas ton
uniforme tulle et tirera dessus qui
décident de passe d'aller contre
exactement voilà donc en fait ce dont
vous parlez aussi à pas cette espèce de
fraternité éphémère mais néanmoins
existantes
c'est le côté rebelles je réfléchis par
moi-même exact je suis d'accord ou pas
et j'oubliais ou pas avec dr voilà donc
ça c'est ce que et est-ce que c'est déjà
un peu une idée que vous véhicules y est
dans le premier d'ailleurs c'est la même
chose
seule la même idée les films se
ressemblent beaucoup aux mails ont même
eu la même époque déjà des le scénario
non c'est pas la même époque le pr marc
dorcel son temps avant guerre
napoléonienne
non mais oui je suis bête je les revois
encore ses petits soldats quoi mais
c'est un pas danser un peu de deux
histoires semblables à deux époques
différentes ou en fait de personnes
surtout bas légèrement coupé de la
guerre oui pour se poser la question
mais ce qu'on avait à faire c'est tenir
exactement passé comme ça c'est un peu
l'un l'autre et vous êtes marqué par ces
histoires de guerre qui très très rock
plein de raisons est
mais la première c'est que les guerres
et notamment en plus la première
mondiale cdc des moments où où les
aberrations sont non plus limite c'était
impossible ou l'aberration devient une
industrie presque au c'est officiel
qu'on fait des choses aberrantes l'état
lui-même devient aberrant labéraudie
mais c'est à dire qu'on envoie des gens
qui n'ont plus envie de se battre se
mettre sur la figure et puis pas non et
puis les puits dans des conditions
absolument abominable et bien très bien
c'est intéressant d'avoir la vision d'un
jeune homme de 25 ans et puis je pense
aussi à ça aussi c'est que on arrive au
centenaire du coup on repense à cette
guerre eva large et l'âge un des 1 dh
parfait où il s'entend moi je ne me
serais pas mariée je vais marier bientôt
et je serai pas un parti mal et je
serais parti sur le front et je serai
prêt mmm et rosie et maillard pense que
ça fait pas rien de se dire ça m on
s'entend avant se préparer pas à l'avion
se préparait à la mort
complètement sur cette belle phrase mais
moins triste
je vous dis au 21 décembre sinon merci
et puis à très bientôt pour deux
prochains films un merci longs ou courts
longs en cours peut-être lent peut pas
tout et neutre on vous souhaite
merci salut